les vendeurs ou les vendeuses dans les
magasins et moi je trouve que vraiment
attendre encore rien dit là moi j'aime
bien les vendeurs dans les boutiques ou
les magasins c'est un métier pas évident
et ils sont toujours là pour nous aider
nous conseillez et parfois même nous
faire cracher note t elle il ya aussi ce
vendeur très malin pour eux de rendre un
produit il est super sympa avec toi il
est cool il fait des blagues à limite le
temps d'une vente ça devient ton
meilleur pote quoi
les quatre
wen avait un devoir et pour les vacances
qu'on devait faire je te casse
maintenant aux juges du taf la whey
l'eau ouais tu peux aller me chercher en
réserve de bottes un fifa de casse
maintenant en plus franchement je sais
pas vous mais moi je pense pas être un
client 1 à 6 par exemple dans une
boutique de vêtements je remplis pas un
t-shirt après l'avoir essayé c'est juste
parce que je sais pas piller un t-shirt
aussi bien que les vendeurs au pliage de
cp excusez moi vous pouvez plier mon
linge de chez moi allez allez y est
d'accord les vendeurs de vêtements ils
sont là pour te donner des petits
conseils sur ce que tu veux acheter
mais moi j'aime pas trop parce que en
même temps il juge les goûts c'est ah
non mais ça va pas du tout
non ça vous gros si ça a pas votre temps
c'est pas pour vous ça monsieur n'ont
pas été non plus là moi ça à pardon eh
bien il est super bien suivant puis moi
j'aime pas les cabines d'essayage déchu
tirent le rideau d'un côté ça s'ouvre de
l'autre côté j'ai cassé
bref au final ya toujours une petite
fente bien gênante où les gens peuvent
te voir à poil
et puis en plus j'ai passé ça vous le
fais moi quand j'ai demandé au vendeur
d'essayer de dix mille produits et que
finalement je prends rien c'est con mais
je culpabilise alors vous en pensez quoi
cette classe de le perdre j'aime pas
trop en fait je prends pas
moi c'est là où j'ai mangé toutes ses
pairs tout seul je veux dire mon patron
que j'ai fait zéro vente
il va milliards et puis je me faire
quitter par me femme quoi ok ok je
prends un porte-clés voiture une
première trop de monde dans le magasin
le vendeur est déjà occupée avec plein
de clients
et toi tu dois attendre ton tour en le
suivant partout comme un chien chien à
ce moment là le vendeur il est tellement
sollicité limite il se prend un peu pour
une star quoi profit si vous avez le
rayon slip à toutes les tailles
ouais j'ai d'abord savoir ce qu'ils font
là chacun son tour d'accord pour qu'il y
ait un lien j'adore votre rayon j'ai
suivi toute vente l'acheteur merci pour
les filles qui veulent une terrible ça
est-ce que vous avez des questions vous
avait la pointure 45
je les ai pas en stock merci carton
jaune ville où vous avez été énorme
contre moi demain je serai là à 9h par
christina
ce qui est sûr c'est que je préfère un
vendeur qui n'a pas la réponse à ce que
je demande plutôt que ce vendeur qui
fait style le savoir mais qui en fait
découvre le produit en même temps que
toi alors la consommation d'énergie
plutôt faible elle a un mode veille et
elf et 4k full hd full hd
ok je crois que vous lisez vraiment la
fiche d'un autre produit un nom un peu
et là c'est canal+ et parfois même
limite tu connais mieux le produit que
lui alors vous avez le mode green
décongélation micro-ondes énergie à peu
près 600 watts voilà c'est génial je
peux payer en plusieurs fois sur le
project
ça me saoule quand les vendeurs et
voltaire fourguer une garantie scei
dramatise tout pour que tu flippes et
que tu apprennes est ce que vous prenez
la garantie non c'est bon merci dommage
c'est dans dix ans votre télé va tomber
en panne à cause d'un incendie dans
votre foyer être même des inondations
têtu la foudre va directement de tomber
sur votre famille études en enfance et
bon stop savent que je ne garantis pas
de garantie c'est bon ok voilà pas de
garanties mais les plus forts que j'ai
connu dans ma vie ça reste quand même
les vendeurs d'instruments de musique
alors eux ils savent vraiment comment te
donner envie d'acheter tout en te
faisant passer pour une petite merde je
crains qu'il n'ait pas accordé 1 je sais
pas si cette voie
[Applaudissements]
il
ouais non mais j'ai pas la prendre en
fait je vais plutôt prendre des cours de
guitare en tout cas j'encourage tous mes
potos vendeurs et vendeuses parce qu'ils
font un métier pas évident surtout
qu'ils doivent tomber sur beaucoup de
clients bien relou alors promis
dorénavant tous essayé d'aider client
exemplaire mais juste un truc
comment ampli tee shirt c'est quoi c'est
le noeud de chaise
au fait vous êtes bientôt 10 millions
d'abonnés à ma chaîne youtube c'est un
truc de ouf
c'est un cap historique dans ma vie donc
continuer à vous abonner c'est
maintenant ou jamais et je lance au
slogan officiel que j'ai inventé de moi
même c'est tout simplement go to 10
millions voilà c'est pas ouf mais jamais
un mois